[Musik]
hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live friedrich merz helge braun norbert
röttgen drei männer zwischen fast 50 und
mitte 60 das soll sie also sein die
neuaufstellung der cdu denn einer von
ihnen wird cdu-chef sie alle drei
kandidieren und deshalb sind wir heute
live mit dem ergebnis des
mitgliederentscheids der cdu und wir
blenden auch einen kleinen countdown
oben in die ecken in fast 15 minuten
soll es losgehen da kann ich da können
wir gemeinsam also immer zwischendrin
drauf schauen dass wir das nicht
verpassen das ist los geht und was
passiert da jetzt heute also 400.000
parteimitglieder der cdu die durften
abstimmen und haben das auch getan mehr
als 60 prozent haben teilgenommen das
macht hat jemand ausgerechnet
248 1360 stimmen und die werden dann
also zeigen ob einer von diesen dreien
mit einem klaren ergebnis
cdu-chef wird neuer cdu chef oder ob da
eben tatsächlich also nochmal quasi die
zweite runde anläuft und wenn ihr fragen
oder kommentare dazu habt weil wir
werden auch gleich mit einer experten
sprechen dann schreibt die jederzeit
gerne in den stream direkt oder auch per
mail an die mailadresse die wir euch
jetzt einblenden und ich habe mir heute
eingeladen andrea römmele sie ist
professorin an der hertie school of
governance und kennt sich also bestens
aus in der materie und mit ihr können
wir vorher und auch nachher sprechen
hallo herr schönen guten tag frau müller
hallo ich grüße sie war jung und jetzt
sind das also drei eigentlich als
bekannte männer man kennt sie ja schon
die waren alle schon länger wirklich im
amt in ämtern und zwei davon haben sogar
schon mal versucht hier cdu chef zu
werden sieht denn so ein neuanfang aus
frau ramelow
nein so sieht natürlich kein neuanfang
aus und ich bin der festen überzeugung
dass egal wer jetzt der neue cdu-chef
wird das eigentlich nur ein cdu-chef für
den übergang sein kann dass es darum
geht diese partei zu einem jetzt auch in
der opposition zusammen zu führen und
erstmal personell und inhaltlich neu
aufzustellen sie haben es vollkommen zu
recht gesagt zwei der drei kandidaten
waren ja anfang des jahres schon einmal
im gespräch zur auswahl gegen haben dann
gegen armin laschet verloren friedrich
merz versuchte es jetzt ein drittes mal
ich glaube das ganze interessant ist
wenn man sich die letzten
wahlen zum parteivorsitz einmal anschaut
dass sich der modus also wer wählt und
natürlich auch ein bisschen wie gewählt
wird weil jetzt eben online gewählt wird
geändert hat in diesem verfahren ist es
jetzt so dass die mitglieder das letzte
wort haben und das ist meiner ansicht
nach auch ein verfahren das am ehesten
für friedrich merz sprechen wird wir
schauen mal gerade live zu hören live
nach berlin und schauen ob sich schon
das tut und danach sprechen wir auch
noch einmal detaillierter über diese
drei kandidaten aber da ist es noch
ruhig wir sehen also drei mikrofone ein
pult und journalisten aber sonst ist
ruhe aber dann schauen wir doch mal
genauer auf diese drei kandidaten und
sprechen dann auch im einzelnen noch mal
genau über jene und fangen wir an mit
friedrich merz der ja also ist auch
schon mal versucht sie haben es auch
schon angesprochen also sogar schon
jetzt zum dritten versucht und friedrich
merz ist also der älteste kandidat mit
66 er war zuletzt
aufsichtsratvorsitzender für den
weltgrößten vermögensverwalter blackrock
und geht als wirtschaftsliberal schon
wirklich in der vergangenheit lang ist
sehr hatte er auch immer schon
machtkämpfe mit der ehemaligen
bundeskanzlerin merkel und jetzt
versucht er also erneut cdu chef zu
werden das erste mal 2018 hat er
verloren gegen annegret kramp
karrenbauer dann hat er es noch mal
versucht da wurde also anfang 2000 21
also gewählt und da hat er also verloren
gegen armin laschet denkt sich dann sind
vielleicht aller guten dinge drei frauen
die frage an sie ist das jetzt
beachtlich dass er sich das jetzt noch
mal getraut also wirklich ein drittes
mal oder was hat das zu bedeuten dass er
das jetzt wirklich hier noch mal wagt
also ich finde es ja schon man kann das
aus unterschiedlichen perspektiven
betrachtet man kann sagen er ist guter
verlierer und er lässt sich nicht
einschüchtern sondern versucht jetzt ein
drittes mal auf der anderen seite kann
man genauso gut sagen mensch hat er den
gong mich gehört also zweimal hat er es
nicht geschafft das macht ja auch was
mit einem kandidaten also wie gesagt man
kann das aus unterschiedlichen
perspektiven
betrachten fakt ist allerdings auch dass
er beim ersten mal als jetzt 2018 gegen
annegret kramp karrenbauer verloren hat
wirklich extrem knapp nur verloren hat
eben haben wenn ich das richtig in
erinnerung habe gerade mal sieben
stimmen gefehlt was bei 1001 delegierten
wirklich sehr wenig ist und er hat
damals schlicht und ergreifend die
falsche rede gehalten er hat keine
parteitags rede gehalten sondern er hat
eine rede gehalten die vielleicht in
einem seminar für internationale politik
gut gewesen wäre aber hat er den
falschen ton getroffen
2002 21 also am anfang des jahres war
die herausforderung ja gegen armin
laschet den ministerpräsidenten von
nordrhein westfalen und dann ja auch
kanzlerkandidaten das war letztendlich
auch ein enges rennen damals auch mit
norbert röttgen als dritten kandidaten
und es ging dann mit laschet und und
märz in die stichwahl auch da
ja kein klares ergebnis für für laschet
natürlich hat laschet gewonnen aber was
wir auch gesehen haben ist das friedrich
merz doch eine eine wirklich große
machtbasis innerhalb der partei hat die
ihn jetzt nun um zur heutigen bereits
bekommen auch sie ihre frage warum
probiert er es denn jetzt noch ein
drittes mal sicherlich ist die der
zuspruch aus der basis aus bestimmten
flügeln der partei ein grund dafür warum
friedrich jetzt warum friedrich merz
jetzt zum dritten mal seinen hut in den
ring wirft und das verfahren ich hab's
ja gerade schon gesagt dass die
mitglieder jetzt eben aus suchen
auswählen dürfen und nicht die
delegierten wird ihm einen vorteil
verschaffen
friedrich merz extrem stark an der basis
oder stark vernetzt und verdrahtet ist
in der partei an der basis gut ankommt
wir wissen aus studien dass die basis
die cdu mitgliedschaft tendenziell
konservativer ist als die cdu
wählerschaft und all das sind gründe
dafür davon auszugehen dass friedrich
merz hier die nase vorne haben wird noch
eine kurze nachfrage zu friedrich merz
mit blick auf die uhr kommen wenn danach
aber auch zu den anderen beiden
kandidaten zusammen die basis
angesprochen und gerade bei jüngeren so
verschieden ist jetzt im vorfeld scheint
er beliebt zu sein er möchte selbst der
anwalt der jungen generation sein hat
erst genannt und er kommt also offenbar
bei der jungen union die hatten das
öffentlich gemacht auch gut an warum ist
das so der älteste kandidat kommt gut
bei den jungen an gerne knapp an dieser
stelle antworten mit blick auf die uhr
und er kommt natürlich auch deswegen gut
an und ist es unabhängig vom alter weil
er ein wahrscheinliches den klarsten
gegenpol zur ampel koalition bildet weil
er die cdu ganz klar als alternative zur
ampel präsentieren wird und
dann schauen wir mal auf den nächsten
kandidat auf helge braun der erst 49
jahre und auch schon bekannt weil er war
in der letzten bundesregierung der
kanzleramtschef von angela merkel und
das ist seine erste kandidatur und das
ist interessant weil oder das ist noch
ein zweiter punkt interessant weil seit
wenigen tagen seien zwei drei tagen ist
bekannt dass er nun auch vorsitzender
des haushaltsausschusses im bundestag
ist und er gilt als merkel-vertrauter
frau remmele da die frage ist dass er
was was helge braun jetzt schaden könnte
dass er da sehr merkel nahe ist im
gegensatz zum märz der sicher von merkel
klar abgrenzen möchte
ja es steht sicherlich nicht für eine
oder oder anders formuliert er steht am
wenigsten für einen neuanfang der cdu
weil er eben so eng und so nah an angela
merkel dran ist und auch die motive
seiner kandidatur sind ja auch ein
bisschen unklar ob er letztendlich
friedrich merz so ein bisschen die show
nehmen möchte ihn das also praktisches
verfahren so weit treiben möchte dass er
mindestens in einen 2
ein gang gehen muss wie gesagt neuanfang
sieht vor allem wenn man auch helge
braun schaut doch anders aus weil er
eben so nah an der kanzlerin dran war
und jetzt dieses bekanntwerden dass er
also auch der vorsitzende des
haushaltsausschusses künftig wird ist es
schon so ne vorzeichen dass er
vielleicht gar nicht denkt dass es wird
ja dass davon kann man ausgehen dass es
hier eine gewisse rolle spielt sollte er
es wider erwarten doch werden ist die
große frage was macht er dann mit dem
mit dem vorsitz aber wie gesagt es gab
ja auch überraschung ob seiner
kandidatur war wirklich niemand damit
gerechnet hat dass jetzt dass jetzt
ausgerechnet helge braun seinen hut in
den ring wirft
und schauen wir noch auf den dritten und
letzten kandidat der es also versucht
und sich bemüht das ist norbert röttgen
norbert röttgen 56 jahre außenpolitiker
ehemaliger umweltminister das schon ein
bisschen was her nach seiner niederlage
bei der landtagswahl in nrw 2012 wurde
er nämlich von der merkel-regierung als
damals eben bundesminister quasi
entlassen und das ist eine zweite
kandidatur kandidatur er hat auch schon
mal versucht im januar da ist es auch
schon märz friedrich merz versucht hatte
und das ist also der dritte im bunde und
wofür steht der dann genau wofür steht
norbert röttgen wenn man jetzt den einen
als merkel nahm sie den anderen eher
merkel fern wofür steht norbert röttgen
ja er steht es auch er merkel fern aber
er steht für eine modernere für eine
zumindest in meinen augen
zukunftsgerichtete hre cdu die auch mit
dem thema umwelt und klima das ja eng
auch mit seiner person verbunden ist ein
thema hätte das bei jungen wählerinnen
und wählern extrem gut ankommt ist ein
ausgewiesener außenpolitiker damit kann
er sicherlich auch punkten punkten er
würde die cdu eher in der mitte des
parteienspektrums
verorten also nicht
weiter rechts wie es beispielsweise mit
einem kandidaten friedrich merz der fall
wäre das wäre also nicht die ganz klare
abgrenzung zur ampel hin oder die
alternative zur ampel hin aber auf der
anderen seite wenn man jetzt aus auswahl
soziologischer perspektive drauf schaut
wissen wir wahlen werden in der mitte
gewonnen
und deswegen auch sinnvoller die partei
in der mitte und eben nicht zu weit
rechts zu positionieren er wie gesagt er
probiert es jetzt zum zweiten mal um den
cdu vorsitz zu kandidieren er ist nach
allem was man hört nicht so gut vernetzt
und verdrahtet innerhalb der partie ist
beispielsweise ein friedrich merz ist
friedrich merz der ganz klar seine
truppen hinter sich habe seine
unterstützer base auch hat das sagt man
norbert röttgen nicht nach aber auch er
wird jetzt einige koalitionen
geschmiedet haben wie gesagt
zusammenfassend ein moderneres gesicht
als es friedrich merz wäre wir schauen
noch mal nach berlin ob da noch alles
ruhig ist glaube fünf minuten haben wir
noch aber es ist noch alles ruhig ich
möchte mal ein paar kommentare von euch
aus dem stream aufgreifen rothaus bei
youtube schreibt ich denke märz wird es
angelika roth bei facebook schließt sich
da an schreibt beim dritten mal klappt
es herr merz also das sind
offensichtlich märz fans es gibt aber
auch andere stimmen er
erinnert soll wenn ich eure namen nicht
so richtig aussprechen bei youtube
schreibt ich finde märz wäre die falsche
wahl röttgen könnte ich mir vorstellen
in vier jahren selbst zu wählen als
wahrscheinlich kanzler aha also das
spricht ja auch jemand schon etwas an
also in vier jahren ich meine wir haben
ja gerade erst hinter uns in vier jahren
wird gewählt aber frau remler ist das
jetzt auch von diesen dreien wer auch
immer es wird wird diese person sich
überhaupt so lange halten haben sie da
schon gefühlte prognose
das ist die erste frage natürlich wird
diese person sich so lange halten ich
sehe diese den neuen parteivorsitzenden
jetzt erst mal als einen mann des
übergangs der die partei beruhigen muss
konsolidieren muss die parteien der
opposition positionieren ein weiterer
punkt es wurde ja auch in den chats oder
in den frei gerade angesprochen ist der
neue vorsitzende dann auch der nächste
kanzlerkandidat
da würde ich ein großes fragezeichen
dahinter machen warum die cdu wird jetzt
auch in den nächsten monaten einen
prozess einen diskussionsprozess starten
wer und nach welchen kriterien eine
kanzlerkandidatin oder ein
kanzlerkandidat ausgesucht wird das sind
die ganz klaren lehren aus dem frühjahr
20 21 als der sonderzug und der lasche
zug quasi ungebremst aufeinander zu
rauschen und man darüber diskutiert hat
nach welchen kriterien wählen wir
überhaupt haus wer wählt aus so was darf
2025 nicht mehr passieren und da wird es
eine diskussion darüber geben deswegen
ist dieser automatismus der
parteivorsitzende hat mehr oder weniger
das erste zugriffsrecht das werden wir
dann nicht mehr haben ich möchte noch
mehr kommentare aufgreifen diesmal ein
bisschen allgemeiner nicht mit so klaren
favoriten und zwar schreibt hier
maximilian schmidt bei youtube schön und
cdu typisch dass der anteil an älteren
männern mit halbglatze bei zwei dritteln
liegt schreibt maximilian schmidt frank
buch war im frank buchholz bei facebook
schreibt ist das jetzt so wichtig der
nachwuchs welt einen dieser alten
politiker so sieht gelebter rückschritt
aus also hier zwei kritische stimmen von
zwei männern in den streams die das eben
als rückschrittlich empfinden warum sind
denn diese drei geworden und wieso ist
da nicht zum beispiel auch eine frau in
ihren reihen gibt es darauf eine antwort
ist ja interessant immer wenn immer wenn
die große krise ist wird er noch lauter
nachdem frauen geschrieben
aber dazu muss man natürlich auch in
einem in dem pool an möglichen
kandidaten genug frauen haben und wenn
man sich die cdu strukturell mal
anschaut wenn man sich auch die
mitgliedschaft anschaut dann ist die
eben sehr männerdominiert oder auch an
der parteibasis wenn man sich die
möglichkeiten anschaut wie man mitmachen
kann dann ist es beispielsweise für
junge frauen die familien haben die job
und familie zusammen denken müssen nicht
unbedingt attraktiv was übrigens genauso
für männer gelte also der verstehen sie
mich nicht falsch aber es ist ein stück
weit auch ein spiegelbild der partei die
eben auch an der basis nicht sonderlich
divers nicht sonderlich jungen gestellt
ist und das ist etwas was sich die
partei für die nächsten jahre auf den
zettel schreiben wo es hier offener zu
werden hier attraktive für frauen für
junge menschen zu werden eine minute
haben wir noch sagt uns der countdown
wir versuchen es noch einmal mit allen
kurzen frage antwort wenn sie jetzt
sagen müssen vielleicht auch von den
themen her was stellen die in den
mittelpunkt norbert röttgen merkt es
vorhin angesprochen der setzt scheinbar
auch auf klimaschutz lässt sich das bei
den anderen auch so aus machen auf
welche themen wird da gesetzt
friedrich merz setzt ja jetzt bewusst
auch so gegen punkt zu seinen
wirtschaftsthemen er ist für
wirtschaftsthemen bekannt spricht jetzt
von sozialer gerechtigkeit die frage ist
ob das so sehr zu ihm kraft und helge
braun wird einfach mit angela merkel mit
der agenda von angela merkel verbunden
da geht es natürlich jetzt auch noch in
corona krisen-management er ist
sicherlich inhalt nicht der farblose
sste der drei
kandidaten röttgen klima umwelt
außenpolitik märz
wirtschaftsthemen der die harte grenze
nach rechts uneben soziale spannungen
polarisierung unser countdown ist zwar
schon abgelaufen wir sind pünktlich aber
ich sehe gerade in berlin tut sich noch
nie geschossen und ich bin glücklich cpu
es noch nicht pünktlich aber könnte
tatsächlich sein dass es gleich losgeht
was dann passiert ist also dass
generalsekretär paul team jagt das
ergebnis verkünden soll wird und danach
wird man mit sicherheit also auch von
den drei kandidaten etwas oder was ist
tatsächlich nach wie vor ruhig aber das
ist ja nicht schlimm das gibt uns ja
auch noch ein bisschen zeit noch weiter
zu sprechen es kann sein dass ich nur
irgendwann vielleicht dann unfreundlich
unterbrechen muss ich wollte noch mal
ein paar kommentare aufnehmen denn da
gibt es tatsächlich neue beziehungsweise
auch fragen haben wir jetzt hannibal
brück bei facebook fragt hat sich denn
jemand aus der jungen generation
beworben sie haben es aber eigentlich
gerade schon angesprochen
nein es hat keiner sein gute in den in
den ring geworfen bzw wurde nicht
vorgeschlagen
friedrich merz hat ja versucht durch
eine team
dann jüngere leute auch eine frau mit in
sein team zu nehmen aber fakt ist es
sind diese drei kandidaten
und zwar hat friedrich merz zwar in
seinem team dann eine eine frau
aufgestellt aber ja diese drei
kandidaten also wer wirklich da den
chefsessel besetzt das sind also männer
ich schaue noch mal hier in eure
kommentare ich glaube dann wird es
wieder sehr spezifisch daher gibt es
also unterschiedliche favoriten und zwar
torben terwort schreibt bei youtube das
beste für die cdu wäre röttgen
verspricht eine sehr breite masse der
bevölkerung an würden sie der aber
zustimmen frau müller ist röttgen
vielleicht wirklich einer der also viele
verschiedene themen bedient und ist das
aber vielleicht auch gleichzeitig das
problem
ja also ich glaube dass das alle drei
verschiedene themen bedienen können aber
es geht darum dass der neue
parteivorsitzende wirklich die gräben in
der cdu schließt die ja seit 34 jahren
offensichtlich sind und jetzt auch durch
die dritte wahl zum parteivorsitz jetzt
noch mal stärker geworden sind also
insofern muss es auch ein kandidat sein
der einen kann der die menschen wieder
zusammenführen kann hinter dem sich die
partei vereint
einen kommentar mächte ich auch noch
gerne aufgreifen und zwar von corinna
lippmann bei facebook sie schreibt über
märz es wäre schlimm erst viel zu
konservativ mir ist schleierhaft warum
er bei der jungen union so beliebt ist
ein kandidat der lobbyisten der macht
der finanzen dazu liebe frau corinna
lippmann nur ein kleiner spoiler und
zwar nach dem ergebnis wenn wir wieder
mit frau ramelow sprechen haben wir auch
tillmann kuban den vorsitzenden der
jungen union eingeladen und können ihnen
das ganz direkt fragen warum ist
friedrich merz da so beliebt dass wird
sich also noch klären es lohnt sich dran
zu bleiben auch für unsere
nachbesprechung so viel sei an dieser
stelle gesagt und jetzt höre ich was auf
meinem hobby schauen mal nach berlin wo
sitzen und ich glaube wir können jetzt
auch ganz live rübergehen es geht jetzt
gleich los und ich gebe jetzt einfach
mal ab an das livebild
im fairen wettstreit mit ihrer ideen den
fragen der mitglieder gestellt
tausende mitglieder haben an der
befragung teilgenommen und heute
erfahren wir das ergebnis
und hier sind sie die kandidaten für den
vorsitz der cdu deutschlands
[Musik]
mit dabei ein bisschen generalsekretär
paul simon und für den wahlvorstand
bundestagsvize präsidentin yvonne
maklers
[Musik]
ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
liebe helge braun lieber friedrich merz
lieber norbert röttgen aber vor allem
liebe mitglieder der cdu deutschlands
die jetzt zuschauen ein spannender tag
nach einer spannenden zeit und die
wollen mag was und ich begrüße sie ganz
herzlich hier live aus dem
konrad-adenauer-haus in berlin wir geben
heute das ergebnis der befragung der
mitglieder bekannt wer soll neuer
vorsitzender der cdu deutschlands werden
und eins steht jetzt schon fest
gewinner dieser befragung sind die
mitglieder der cdu deutschlands die
beteiligt werden die ihre stimme
abgegeben haben die diskutiert haben und
an dieser stelle will ich schon einmal
im namen glaube ich alle mitglieder den
drei kandidaten für diesen tollen und
auf fairen wettbewerb um die zukunft der
cdu deutschlands und welchen beitrag wir
für die zukunft unseres landes liefern
können und beitragen können danke das
war toll das hat freude gemacht
ja lieber helge braun lieber friedrich
merz lieber norbert röttgen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren auch von mir
ein herzliches willkommen und ich tue
dies auch sehr gern im namen des
gesamten
wahlvorstandes dem gehörten neben mir
dem paar und dem pc-markt die gitta
connemann an der thomas jarzombek ansgar
heveling tamara zieschang und der
patrick schnieder auch von ihnen ein
herzliches willkommen ich bedanke mich
bei den gesamten wahlvorstand natürlich
auch für die gute zusammenarbeit in den
letzten wochen wir haben das
wahlverfahren begleitet wir haben die
wahl begleitet und heute liegt ein
ergebnis vor genau zu diesem kommen wir
gleich aber dieses ergebnis ist nur ein
teil des erneuerungsprozesses wir haben
nach der bundestagswahl mit einem
umfassenden erneuerungsprozess begonnen
wir haben die kreisvorsitzenden
eingeladen nach berlin zu kommen weil
wir gesagt haben es ist wichtig dass wir
jetzt gemeinsam miteinander darüber
sprechen wie geht es weiter mit unserer
großen volkspartei wir haben
kommissionen ein gesetz zur aufarbeitung
des wahlergebnisses des wahlkampfes und
vor allem über die frage zu diskutieren
mit möglichst vielen in der partei auch
unter beteiligung externer rates wie
stellen wir uns nicht nur personell
sondern auch inhaltlich und strukturell
neu auf das heißt diese
erneuerungsprozess ist ein ganz
lebendiger prozess in der cdu
deutschlands und an dieser stelle
erlauben sie mir nicht nur danke zu
sagen bei allen die sich beteiligen
daran bei den hunderttausenden von
mitgliedern ich will ganz persönlich
auch danke sagen gerade in hinblick auf
die mitgliederbefragung bei allen
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern der
cdu deutschlands hier im
konrad-adenauer-haus die nicht nur in
diesem jahr und das ist immer so in
bundestagswahl kämpfen dass man hart
arbeitet aber auch gerade in den wochen
und monaten danach die unglaublichen
einsatz gezeigt haben bei der begleitung
dieser mitgliederbefragung das war sehr
sehr viel arbeit und hier wurde mit
herzblut und viel engagement gearbeitet
ich bin stolz auf den mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter der cdu deutschlands im
konrad adenauer haus
und die mitglieder
haben es in der hand einen vorschlag zu
machen aus ihrer sicht werde neuer cdu
vorsitzender werden soll und die von
marx was hat die ersten zahlen für uns
ja wo ist das ich habe zumindest einige
daten und fakten die jetzt schon
vorliegen zur anzahl der wählerinnen und
wähler also fast eine viertelmillion der
cdu mitglieder haben ihre stimme
abgegeben
es sind genau
1617 die online ihre stimme abgegeben
haben und 115
1743 die per brief gewählt haben das
sind knapp zwei drittel aller mitglieder
64 31 prozent an der kleine korrektur
gab es heute noch was den anteil
anbelangt mit dem auszählen der stimmen
von
familienmitgliedern konnten wir nun auf
eine beteiligung von genau
66,0 2 prozent kommen danke liebe
mitglieder für dieses historisch starke
ergebnis für diese historische
beteiligung das setzt einfach maßstäbe
in der deutschen parteienlandschaft und
zeigt die cdu ist eine mitmachpartei
ein unglaublich starke ein unglaublich
starke beteiligung und wir sehen wie
lebendig die partei zwei drittel stimmen
ab beteiligen sich das haben wir in den
vielen formaten gesehen hier beim bei
der arena im adenauer-haus aber bei
vielen anderen veranstaltungen und er
hat unglaublichen einsatz gezeigt vor
ort auch in vielen veranstaltungen
videokonferenzen mit großer leidenschaft
mit tollen ideen haben wir über die
zukunft der cdu gestritten und
diskutiert in der sache meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren ich will sie
nicht länger auf die folter spannen
jetzt das ergebnis der befragung der
mitglieder der cdu deutschlands jeder
zentimeter auf den balken steht für
viele tausende mitglieder wer wird neuer
cdu vorsitzender nach befragung der
mitglieder auf helge braun entfallen
12,1 prozent auf friedrich auf dem
rücken fallen
25,8 prozent und auf friedrich merz
62,1 prozent der abgegebenen stimmen
das ist die absolute mehrheit
eindeutiges
ein eindeutiges ergebnis
ich will an dieser stelle sagen meine
damen und herren weil einige vorab
danach gefragt haben wie haben sich denn
welche gruppen entschieden also
diejenigen die per brief abgestimmt
haben und diejenigen die online
abgestimmt haben gab es da unterschiede
haben unterschiedliche kandidaten
gewonnen ich kann ihnen sagen heute nein
die abweichungen sind sehr geringfügig
und auch in beiden verfahren sowohl bei
der briefwahl als auch bei dem online
verfahren hat friedrich merz deutlich
die absolute mehrheit erreicht lieber
friedrich merz herzlichen glückwunsch zu
diesem tollen ergebnis danke norbert
röttgen danke helge braun für ihren
einsatz
auch von meiner seite ein herzliches
glück einen herzlichen glückwunsch und
der designierte parteivorsitzende hat
jetzt das wort und wir müssen noch frage
wenn ich das soll sagt friedrich mehr
die nominierung der räder an nimmt ja
vielen dank wie wir vor zehn jahren
liebe yvonne markus meine damen und
herren ich bedanke mich zunächst einmal
bei allen unseren mitgliedern
schon gestern war ein guter tag für die
cdu als wir die ersten ergebnisse gehört
haben was die beteiligung ausmacht und
das wir heute bestätigt bekommen dass
zwei drittel unserer mitglieder an
dieser mitgliederbefragung teilnehmen
ist ein beeindruckendes und tolles
ergebnis einer partei die lebt und die
mitgestalten will und das ist glaube ich
ein gewinn für uns alle ich bedanke mich
war in beiden mitbewerbern mitstreitern
die wie helge braun lieber norbert
röttgen das waren herausfordernde tage
und wochen aber und zwar an ein gutes
miteinander zwischen uns dreien und ich
denke das hat der partei gut getan wie
wir es gemacht haben dass wir es gemacht
haben und das hat sicherlich auch
maßstäbe gesetzt nicht nur für uns auch
für andere ich möchte mich herzlich
bedanken bei paul signac und bei allen
die hier im adenauer-haus
mitgewirkt haben
das aber haus
lassen sie mich das einfach mal so sagen
dass althaus die cdu diese
parteizentrale steht seit drei jahren im
ausnahmezustand
und das sind zeiten gewesen die müssen
sich auch so nicht wiederholen aber dass
wir das geschafft haben dass die
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter das
durchgehalten haben dass wir hier eine
so tolle macht
ermutigendes zeichen und ich möchte mich
noch mal ganz herzlich bei allen
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern bedanken
stellvertretend bei dir lieber paul du
hast das hier jetzt mehrfach gemacht es
ist jederzeit fair gewesen es ist den
bewerbern gegenüber offen und fair
gewesen und ich denke ich darf das auch
im namen der beiden mitbewerber sagen
herzlichen dank für deine arbeit danke
schön
ich bedanke mich bei denen die in meinem
engsten team diese arbeit der letzten
wochen begleitet haben bei mario czaja
und christina stumpf
das hat große freude gemacht mit diesem
sich neue herausbildenden führungsteam
für die cdu deutschlands schon diese
arbeit zu leisten und vorbehaltlich
natürlich der zustimmung des bundes
parteitages ich freue mich ganz
besonders auf die zusammenarbeit mit
euch beiden aber auch mit allen die dann
weiter dazu gehören ja und last but not
least dies ist keine endgültige
entscheidung sondern es ist eine
entscheidung der mitglieder ein votum
der mitglieder der bundesvorstand der
cdu wird dieses votum so hat er es
beschlossen unabhängig von der person
übernehmen als seinen vorschlag für den
bundesparteitag im januar das heißt wir
werden im januar den vorsitzenden und
auch den gesamten bundesvorstand der cdu
deutschlands dann erst endgültig und
wirksam wählen ich biete allen
kandidatinnen und kandidaten schon heute
ein gutes miteinander auf dem weg
dorthin an aber dann insbesondere nach
diesen wahlen im januar eine gute
zusammenarbeit für die cdu in der cdu
und auch für unser land ich werde nicht
nachlassen das immer wieder zu sagen wir
sind nicht für uns selbst da sondern wir
haben einen auftrag auch hier in berlin
in der opposition die wählerinnen und
wähler der cdu haben auch uns einen
auftrag gegeben und diesen auftrag zu
erfüllen in der deutschen politischen
öffentlichkeit aber auch im deutschen
bundestag das wird unsere aufgabe auch
in der opposition sein und ich werde
darum bemüht sein das mit ganzer kraft
mit allem was wir können auch zu leisten
so dass wir die nächsten zwei jahre und
das ist die amtszeit eines neuen
vorstandes dass wir die nächsten zwei
jahre hier einfach zeigen dass die cdu
genauso ist wie wir sie jetzt
wahrgenommen haben eine lebendige partei
die mit entscheiden die mitmachen will
und eine partei die auch als volkspartei
in der bundesrepublik deutschland im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert ihren
platz haben wird ich weiß was da für uns
alle auf uns zukommt ich weiß was das
für mich persönlich bedeutet aber ich
nehme diese nominierung unserer
mitglieder ich freue mich darauf auf
gute zusammenarbeit mit wirklich alle
[Applaus]
glaubt
wenn ich wollte nicht wollte nicht
diesen applaus in dieser besonderen
stunde nämlich das war zum ersten mal
dass wir so etwas gemacht haben
unterbrechen ich möchte zunächst die er
friere ich persönlich ganz herzlich
gratulieren
und ich wünsche dir
erfolg und freude und ich wünsche dir
erfolg für unsere cdu in deiner arbeit
als parteivorsitzender wenn du dann auf
dem parteitag gewählt wirst deutschland
braucht die cdu und darum wünsche ich
dir erfolg für die cdu für deutschland
und für europa ich möchte auch
unterstreichen dass das ein großartiger
erfolg ist der in der großen teilnahme
liegt
250.000 mitglieder haben gesagt wir
wenden uns nicht ab nach einer bitteren
niederlage sondern wir wollen teil eines
neuen anfangs seien das ist ein großes
kapital das zeigt die cdu es eine starke
partei und das ist großartig und wir
alle können darauf stolz sein und
dankbar sein ich möchte einen besonderen
dank natürlich ausdrücken gegenüber
denjenigen die mir ihr vertrauen
geschenkt haben das weiß ich
wertzuschätzen es berührt mich bei jedem
einzelnen mitglied bei jedem mann frau
jüngere ältere die mir vertraut haben
die partei zu führen ganz ganz
herzlichen dank an all diejenigen aber
genauso klar wie ich diesen dank
aussprechen und wirklich empfinde tief
empfinde ist genauso klar jetzt ist
entschieden und jetzt wird die cdu
gemeinsam kämpfen für unsere
christdemokratische politik für unsere
werte und wie wir deutschland gestalten
wollen viel erfolg und der cdu in
deutschland
ja lieber friedrich merz erst mal von
meiner seite ganz herzlichen glückwunsch
zu diesem klaren wahlsieg und auch von
meiner seite die volle unterstützung für
die arbeit als vorsitzender der cdu nach
dieser niederlage haben wir viel zu tun
um die cdu nach vorne zu bringen und mit
diesem rückenwind von zwei drittel
unserer mitglieder glaube ich kann man
wirklich sagen
ist das ein großartiges ergebnis was
dazu führt dass wir es als cdu
geschlossen aufbrechen können ich will
meinen teil dazu tun auch ich möchte
mich bedanken bei allen die mich bei
dieser wahl unterstützt haben wir haben
eine sehr kurze wahlkampf zeit gehabt
das hat mich als neuen kandidaten in
diesem reigen herausgefordert aber wir
haben auch unglaublich viel darüber
diskutiert wie wir die cdu als partei
weder organisatorisch digitaler und
moderner machen können das sind glaube
ich alles dinge die auch nach diesem
wahlkampf bleiben die ich gerne
einbringen möchte und deshalb herzlichen
dank an meine unterstützer herzlichen
dank an alle cdu mitglieder die an
dieser wahl teilgenommen haben es gab
vorher so viele die geahnt haben dass
wir möglicherweise eine schwache
wahlbeteiligung haben und jetzt setzen
wir maßstäbe auch für andere parteien
dass es glaube ich ein großartiges
ergebnis und deshalb vielen herzlichen
dank an alle mitglieder die machen uns
den mut dass die cdu schnell wieder
stark wird
vielen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank helge braun norbert röttgen
und friedrich merz und sie haben jetzt
die möglichkeit fragen zu stellen sowohl
an den wahlvorstand mit yvonne mack was
an mich als generalsekretär aber
natürlich vor allem an die kandidaten
für den cdu parteivorsitz ihre war rings
wird das moderieren sehr gerne dann die
erste frage bitte von herrn blank von
dpa
ja herr merz sie haben gute
zusammenarbeit mit allen versprochen
gerade eben gilt das auch für den
fraktionsvorsitzenden werden sie nach
dem fraktionsvorsitz greifen
das thema steht zur zeit nicht auf der
tagesordnung und deswegen mache ich mir
darüber auch keine gedanken
dann eine frage von frau vaters hier
vorne in der dritten reihe von rmd
herz sie gelten ja immer als vertreter
vor allem das konservativen des
wirtschaftsflügels der partei wie mit
welchen themen wollen sie versuchen
den anderen teil der partei für den sie
auch zuständig sind jetzt mitzunehmen
und an die beiden anderen kandidaten die
frage werden sie antreten für einen
platz im obersten führungs also im
präsidium möglicherweise auch für den
stellvertretenden parteivorsitz
vorfahrt ist es ist als
parteivorsitzender für mich zukünftig
selbstverständlich dass alle teile der
partei mitwirken müssen an dem was wir
auch an zukünftigen aufgaben zu bestehen
haben und ich habe auch aus diesem grund
schon das amt des vize präsidenten des
wirtschaftsrates vor einigen wochen
abgegeben und ich werde
selbstverständlich auch für die partei
in der ganzen breite stehen und auch
alle themen mit behandeln die unsere
partei als wichtig empfindet und ich
hoffe dass es mir gelingt auch alle
anderen in die führung der partei so zu
integrieren dass daraus wird er wirklich
wieder ein ein bild eines ganzen wird wo
auch unterschiedliche politische ideen
meinungen und strömungen ihren platz
finden ich werde jedenfalls alles tun um
das zu erreichen
dann bitte herr delfs hier vorne von
bloomberg
also nachfrage entschuldigung in schwung
bei der nachfrage waren noch die haben
natürlich
meine vorstellung ist dass der
designierte vorsitzende und wir beide
darüber gespräche führen wie das
erfolgen soll und darum können wir ja
heute noch nicht zu sagen weil die das
gespräch haben wir heute noch nicht
geführt aber ich gehe davon aus dass wir
darüber sprechen und dann zu einem
ergebnis kommen und
ich schließe mich da norbert röttgen und
seine entschuldigung herr dfb-treffer
nord bloomberg märz
die cdu hat ja jetzt in den letzten
wochen ein 1 1 er
was hier passiert ist die
oppositionsrolle angeht noch ein eher
gemäßigten eindruck gemacht und ruhigen
eindruck auch der derzeitige
fraktionsvorsitzende reihe ich sage sehr
gemäßigt in seiner oppositionsarbeit wir
sind jetzt dafür bekannt dass sie ein
bisschen offensiver an die dinge angehen
können wir denn jetzt erwarten dass die
cdu der oppositionskurs der cdu sich
jetzt auch unter ihrer führung
verschaffen wirklich über der regierung
des erfahrungsgemäß und ich kann das
sagen weil ich so eine phase ja schon
einmal miterlebt habe braucht es seine
zeit bis eine partei und auch eine
bundestagsfraktion aus dem regierungs
modus in den oppositions modus
gewechselt hat das geht nicht über nacht
insbesondere dann wenn man so lange und
so erfolgreich an der regierung war aber
wir werden uns natürlich auch auf diese
rolle einstellen ich werde meine
erfahrungen einbringen aber auch neue
aspekte diskutieren wie wir diese rolle
wahrnehmen nur eines glaube ich kann ich
für die gesamte partei und für die
gesamte bundestagsfraktion auch sagen so
habe ich es auch in den letzten tagen
und wochen von allen empfunden wir
werden hier keine fundamental opposition
machen wir werden eine konstruktive
opposition sein aber es werden eben
beide teile dazu gehören wir werden
eigene vorschläge machen aber wir werden
die regierung so wie es unsere
parlamentarische demokratie ja vorsieht
auch kritisieren begleiten wenn es
notwendig ist hart kritisieren aber wir
werden ihr auch zustimmen wenn wir in
der sache davon überzeugt sind dass
etwas richtig ist was diese regierung
macht damit ist die cdu auch in der
opposition und das ist jetzt das dritte
mal in unserer geschichte dass wir so
etwas zu tun haben damit ist die cdu als
opposition immer gut gefahren und es
gibt keinen grund für mich daran etwas
zu ändern da die nächste frage bitte
herr gartmann vom spiegel
ich habe die journalisten fragen weiter
laufen haben wir hier aber die
möglichkeit eure fragen aufzugreifen und
das möchte ich gerne machen ich habe
noch mal die möglichkeit mit andrea
römmele der politikwissenschaftlerin
darüber zu sprechen und auch danach noch
mit themen kuban dem vorsitzenden der
jungen union das wird sicher auch
spannend zunächst schauen wir aber mal
auf das ergebnis schauen es uns nochmal
schwarz auf weiß an es gibt nämlich ganz
klar eine absolute mehrheit für
friedrich merz mit
62,1 prozent
das zeigen die er vielleicht auch gleich
noch mal also friedrich merz der hat er
klar der hat ja klar also die mehrheit
geholt dann auf platz 2 norbert röttgen
wenn man so will mit 25,8 prozent aber
eben wirklich deutlich drunter und dann
das nochmal noch deutlich darunter helge
braun mit 12,1 prozent
das bedeutet jetzt also dass friedrich
merz damit klar dominiert ist für den
parteitag im januar und da dann auch
noch mal gewählt werden muss so das
können wir jetzt mal besprechen dieses
ergebnis mit andrea römmele denn das war
ja jetzt doch ziemlich eindeutig sie
haben es auch so ein bisschen
vorhergesehen aber dass es so deutlich
kommt war war ihnen das klar
also ich habe schon damit gerechnet dass
friedlich mehr hat diese wahl für sich
entscheiden wird in der klarheit also
dass es wirklich über 60 prozent ist hat
mich jetzt doch erstaunt aber es zeigt
einfach den rückhalt den er an der basis
hat er ist der mann der basis und das
hat man jetzt auch ganz eindrücklich
gesehen und es tut der partei auch gut
dass man hier jetzt nicht noch mal einen
zermürbenden zweiten wahlgang starten
muss um dann letztendlich den neuen
parteivorsitzenden zu küren sondern die
würfel sind gefallen sie sind klar
gefallen es ist ein klarer auftrag für
friedrich merz und mit dieser klarheit
geht ist es eben auch schon ein erster
schritt hin dazu wieder diese partei
wieder mehr zusammenzuführen mehr zu
einem friedrich merz hat es ja auch in
seinen in seinem kurzen statement jetzt
gesagt er ist der parteivorsitzende
aller mitglieder auch der jedem bin eben
nicht gewählt haben aber für diesen
einigungsprozess der jetzt eben ansteht
ist dieses klare ergebnis wichtig jetzt
helge braun ja mit seinen 12,1 prozent
wirklich ganz am ende ist das vielleicht
auch ein klarer schlag jetzt sage ich
mal gegen die alte merkel zeit gegen die
merkel regierung will man da jetzt
wirklich was ganz anderes
ach das würde ich so nicht sehen ich
glaube dass die dass die nominierung von
helge braun oder das helge braun seien
gut in den ring geworfen hat keiner so
richtig verstanden hat also was
eigentlich seine motivlage war man hatte
ihn nicht so ganz auf dem auf dem schirm
auf dem radar und hat vielleicht die
kandidatur deswegen auch nicht ganz so
ernst genommen und so lässt sich auch
das ergebnis interpretieren jetzt möchte
ich gerne mal die user fragen hier auch
mit einbinden in jemand der sich so was
ähnliches wie chris bei youtube nennt
fragt führt die wahl von märz zu einer
weiteren verzahnung von wirtschaft und
politik auf seiten der cdu denn märz
gilt ja als mann der wirtschaft als
wirtschafts freund
die frage an mich jetzt gerichte die
frage an sie ja ob das zu einer weiteren
zäsur erzähle ich hatte gerade mein
aussetzer in der in der leitung ganz
klar also märz gilt als
wirtschaftsliberaler als mann der
wirtschaft und natürlich werden hier
wirtschaftliche interessen wieder eine
große rolle spielt aber ich würde es
jetzt auch nicht überbewerten die cdu
mit beziehungs die union war schon immer
eine partei die eben eine gewisse
wirtschaftsnähe hat aber es geht ja
nicht nur darum eine wirtschaftsnahe zu
haben es geht eben auch darum
wirtschaftskompetenz zu vermitteln man
muss das thema eben auch mit einer
kompetenz verbinden und das ist
sicherlich etwas was friedrich merz in
den nächsten jahren versuchen wird dass
die union das die cdu wieder die partei
ist die für wirtschaftskompetenz steht
so ich das noch mal mehr kommentare und
fragen hier auch auf und zwar ganz viel
es gab glückwünsche für friedrich merz
der ja auch so klar gewonnen hat das
habe ich also oft gesehen und gelesen
bunch of numbers schreibt bei youtube
schlecht für die cdu gut für deutschland
da können wir jetzt nur rätselraten wie
das genau gemeint das aber es gibt auch
noch mehr fragen und zwar hier zum einen
schreibt tobi bei youtube kann der
bursche ist und hinter den 66-jährigen
märz sich lange im amt halten oder wird
er auch nach misserfolgen direkt wieder
abgesägt werden
und er übernimmt ganz klar die cdu in
ganz turbulenten zeiten eher ich meine
als er 2018 das erste mal angetreten ist
war der blick aufs kanzleramt gerichtet
jetzt ist es der gang in die opposition
er muss die cdu in der opposition
konsolidieren und neu ausrichten das ist
eine ganz andere aufgabe als es
ursprünglich die aufgabe 2018 war
interessant war dass friedrich merz in
seinen ausführungen jetzt erstmal über
die nächsten zwei jahre gesprochen hat
wie er die nächsten zwei jahre gestalten
will dass es auf die nächsten zwei jahre
ankommt und wir hatten es ja vorhin
schon mal in unserer unterhaltung
freyung dass davon auszugehen ist dass
der kandidat der jetzt gewählt wird
jetzt ist es friedrich merz auch ein
gewisser übergangskandidat ist mal sehen
wer 2025 der kanzlerkandidat oder die
kanzlerkandidatin der union wird wie die
cdu dann aufgestellt ist da wird noch
wahnsinnig viel passieren was wir alle
gar nicht vorhersagen können ich glaube
das primäre ziel ist es jetzt die cdu zu
stabilisieren hinter sich zu vereinen
die grabenkämpfe zu beenden in der ob
positionen anzukommen und eben dann auch
wieder inhaltlich zu profilieren damit
haben sie auch schon eine weitere frage
hiervon timbo bei youtube beantwortet er
wollte nämlich wissen wie wahrscheinlich
es ist dass herr merz im nächsten jahr
fraktionsvorsitzender und dann 2025
kanzler wird er hatte auch tatsächlich
tempo sich zu dem fraktionsvorsitz auch
geäußert das war also die erste frage
eines journalisten und hat gesagt dass
das für ihn aktuell nicht an der
tagesordnung sei soviel dazu noch ein
paar mehr kommentare zum beispiel ich
habe mich da ganz kurz oder lang etwas
dazu sagen ja bitte
ist natürlich eine interessante frage
was mit dem mit dem fraktionsvorsitz
passiert es wird keine anderen antwort
von friedrich merz zu kurz nach dem
wahlsieg zu rechnen aber ich glaube
schon dass der stuhl von brinkhaus
wackeln weil es natürlich friedrich merz
auch eine gewisse sichtbarkeit gibt eine
sichtbarkeit in der debatte in der
fraktion insofern würde ich mich nicht
wundern wenn er dann auch nach dem
fraktionsvorsitz greifen wird er wurde
ja auch gefragt in einer dieser
journalisten fragen die wir noch gehört
haben wie jetzt die cdu in der
opposition auftreten wird und hat sich
da so ein bisschen zumindest zeit
verschafft haben sie das auch so
wahrgenommen weil er meinte es braucht
zeit von einer regierungspartei
überzugehen eine oppositionspartei wieso
verschafft er sich da so ein bisschen
zeit um die erwartung irgendwie zu
dämpfen
ja natürlich er muss ja wie gesagt also
ich finde er hat da eigentlich
eine ganz gute antwort gegeben er sagt
den jahren müssen jetzt erstmal in der
opposition ankommen ganz klar aber er
hat auch gesagt wir werden
oppositionsarbeit leisten das heißt
konstruktiv kritik üben aber wenn wir
eben auch die regierung unterstützen
können in manchen dingen dann werden wir
das auch tun ich glaube das war so ein
hinweis auch auf
jetzt diese ganzen diskussion die wir
was corona maßnahmen anbelangt haben
werden was eine mögliche impfpflicht
anbelangt haben werden also dass er der
konstruktive opposition angekündigt was
sowohl inhaltliche auseinandersetzung
anbelangt aber auch unterstützung thema
was ich hier öfter in den kommentaren
leser deswegen wäre es auch wichtig das
glaube ich mal anzusprechen also es gibt
kommentare die so ein bisschen in die
richtung gehen beispielsweise markus
zink bei youtube jetzt ist es auch
begründet warum die cdu künftig neben
der afg sitzt sitzen muss also einige
die glauben das könnte jetzt also
konservativer noch werden mit einem
friedrich merz an der spitze und ronny
freier bei youtube hat dazu eben auch
konkret die frage wird eine
zusammenarbeit mit der afg nun
wahrscheinlicher
nein das halte ich nach wie vor für für
extrem unwahrscheinlich
das hat auch friedrich merz immer wieder
gesagt dass die abgrenzung nach rechts
eben eine abgrenzung ist was aber
natürlich nicht heißt dass die cdu an
sich weiter weiter von der mitte weg
nach rechts wandern wird aber eine
zusammenarbeit mit der ard wird es auch
unter friedrich merz nicht geben was
allerdings der fall ist ist da würde ich
jetzt so ein blick nach ostdeutschland
werfen ist das in ost als die
ostdeutschen cdu parteivorsitzenden die
wahl von friedrich merz sehr begrüßt
haben ich habe jetzt in der pause auch
ganz kurze auf den einen oder anderen
twitter-account geschaut sie versprechen
sich von friedrich merz von einem
parteivorsitzenden friedrich merz so
einiges um eben auch die klare
abgrenzung zur afd
okay das ist an dieser stelle eine klare
antwort auf die frage die dargestellt
wurde was öfter kam jetzt eben gerade
also es wurde so wurde auch das ganze
eingeläutet die cdu hat sich so ein
bisschen selbst gelobt sage ich jetzt
mal für diesen prozess den sie da also
abgehalten haben diese
mitgliederbefragung haben eben auch ganz
klar gesagt das sei ein starkes zeichen
für ihre partei und jetzt kommt hier
eine frage von timo bei youtube der sich
fragt also ist dieser prozess hier bei
der cdu mit dem von der spd vor vier
jahren vergleichbar
vor vier jahren das heißt bevor
frau esken und herr walter bayerns
gewählt wurden oder noch mal weiter
davor dass das wäre jetzt meine große
kino vielleicht schreibt uns das noch
mal bei frau remmele kann mit sicherheit
auch auf beide
noch so ein bisschen erläutern also die
spd hat ja ganz unterschiedliche
erfahrungen mit mitgliederbefragungen
gehabt beim letzten mal war es so dass
es dann regionalkonferenzen gab dass man
sich immer teams vorgestellt haben jetzt
war der cdu war es eben diese diese
einzellösung wie gesagt unterschiedliche
die unterschiedliche parteien haben
diese formate mal mehr mal weniger
ausprobiert bei der bei der
spd jetzt als lars klingbeil als zum ko
vorsitzenden gewählt wurde weil es eben
keine mitgliederbefragung das ändert
sich auch immer mal wieder bei der cdu
wir erinnern uns noch an die worte von
armin laschet der damals ganz klar
gesagt hat das probieren wir jetzt aber
das ist eine ganz große ausnahme so die
worte damals von armin laschet ich muss
ihm recht geben es ist ein erfolg
wahnsinnig viele haben mitgemacht fast
zwei drittel der parteimitglieder was
wirklich außergewöhnlich ist muss man
sagen und es ist auch schön wenn man
praktisch innerparteilich eine auswahl
hat also der prozess an sich ist nicht
nur gut abgelaufen sondern eben auch
gibt dem neuen vorsitzenden auch
wirklich legitimität mit zwei drittel
der mitglieder es ist schon ganz
beachtlich zusammen hat die spd glaube
ich wenn ich mich richtig erinnere nie
hingekriegt dass sich so viele daran
beteiligt haben vielleicht noch ein wort
zu friedrich merz der jetzt bei seiner
dritten kandidatur wo es dann auch
geklappt hat so ein bisschen auch seine
rolle eher ändern muss er war ja sonst
immer wenn wir uns erinnern an seine
letzten kandidaten so der außenseiter
der gegen das establishment
gewettert hat oder sich gegen das
establishment
gestellt hat das muss er jetzt ablegen
das wird er auch ablegen da bin ich ganz
sicher und jetzt wird es praktisch darum
gehen die partei zu einen lassen sie uns
kurz noch auf das team schauen dass er
sich zusammenstellen möchte zum einen
mario czaja der soll sein
generalsekretär werden ein mann aus
ostberlin der er zum sozialflügel der
partei zählt und stellvertreterin von
shire soll christina stumpf werden was
sagt denn dieses team das er sich da so
zusammengestellt hat auch noch ein
bisschen über das weitere jahr über die
zukunft unter friedrich merz dann
vielleicht aus
ja das ist eben der versuch
diverser und jünger und auch weiblicher
zu werden und eben in unterschiedliche
bereiche der cdu hinein zu reichen was
sie an sich eigentlich eine kluge
strategie ist jetzt sind wir mal
gespannt wie das präsidium der cdu sich
zusammensetzt wie diverse jungen wie
weiblich es da aussehen wird aber diese
diversität braucht friedrich merz auch
um wie gesagt in den unterschiedlichen
bereichen einzureichen und um auch
glaubhaft bestimmte themen zu besetzen
und dann ist ja auch noch klar die
bundestagswahl die es weit weg aber es
gibt die landtagswahlen in nrw zum
beispiel gerade als aller nächste hürde
erst mal wie wichtig ist es vielleicht
auch sich da jetzt ganz intensiv als cdu
darauf vorzubereiten wird daran gemessen
werden auch nach dem abschneiden dann
dort bei der landtagswahl
ja natürlich ist es so
landtagswahlen sind immer gradmesser wie
die partei da steht unbezahlt eben immer
auf das konto des parteivorsitzenden ein
oder eben auch nicht
rheinland nicht rheinland-pfalz
nordrhein-westfalen entschuldigung
nordrhein westfalen wählt im mai das
bevölkerungsreichste bundesland der
jetzt gerade frisch ins amt gewählte
herr wüst nachfolger von armin laschet
hat hier eine nicht ganz einfachen stand
und friedrich merz
parteivorsitz wäre schon gleich am
anfang beschädigt wenn
nordrhein-westfalen wieder an die spd
geht würde ich sehe jetzt erst eine
frage im chat die zu unserer
vorhergehenden eigentlich sehr gut passt
bisschen komme also einen kommentar und
zwar stefanie griesbaum bei facebook
schreibt damit ist ja wohl klar dass es
keine moderne partei ist und in nächster
zeit auch keine werden wird frauen
werden neben merz keine chance haben
weiter wie bisher ist die devise schade
röttgen wäre sicher etwas moderner
gewesen aber die wahl zeigt deutlich
dass es der cdu ausschließlich um macht
bald geht sonst um nichts stadt
beschreibt stefanie griesbaum bei
facebook aber sie sagten gerade also sie
glauben dass vielleicht zumindest mit
einer christina stumpi als teil seines
teams schon auch an die frauen
mitgedacht werden war das der plan
ja also um auf die frage einzugehen die
die frage war ja ob es jetzt der der cdu
wirklich nur um machterhalt geht wenn es
der cdu wirklich um macht geht also um
die rückeroberung der macht dann geht es
ja gar nicht anders als
mit einer diversen aufstellung wir
müssen uns ja auch mal vergegenwärtigen
wie die die cdu wird ja dann auch immer
mit der ampel verglichen die jetzt
deutlich jünger deutlich diverser
deutlich weiblicher ist und und damit
damit muss die cdu ja auch mithalten und
insofern und es weiß ein friedrich merz
auch dass er hier mit jungen mit
dynamischen leuten arbeiten muss die
eben auch für die neue generation der
cdu stehen die die cdu dann in die
nächste regierungsperiode für führen und
dass es nicht mit politikern passieren
kann die schon 30 jahre im geschäft sind
ich finde es gibt noch mehr spannende
kommentare sind so verschiedene
themengebiete die wir hier wirklich
nochmal ansprechen können und zwar
schreibt hier maximiliane muster frau
bei youtube möglicherweise tut das auch
der fdp w märz passt ja auch gut zu den
neoliberalen da brauchen sie die fdp
nicht mehr nur noch die jungen die
lindner einfangen konnte wird er nicht
begeistern was sagen sie zu seiner
aussage frau camilla
also ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das der der
fdp sowie zwei dass die anderen parteien
die regierungsparteien schauen dann
natürlich mit spannung darauf wäre jetzt
der neue parteivorsitzende wird und sie
werden mit friedrich merz auch gut im
bundestag zusammen arbeiten also glaube
ich jetzt nicht dass es da so große
schmerzen bei der fdp gibt es gibt die
frage von steinbock 880 bei youtube was
wird sich durch märz
gesellschaftspolitisch ändern hat er
sich dazu im vorfeld schon konkreter
geäußert
na ja ich würde es anders formulieren
ich würde in denen ich würde jetzt nicht
auf friedrich merz gucken und schauen
was sich da gesellschaftspolitisch
ändern würde sondern ich würde in den
koalitionsvertrag schauen und der
koalitionsvertrag der ampel bringt sehr
viele gesellschaftspolitische änderungen
mit sich meiner ansicht nach ist es ein
sehr progressiver teil des
koalitionsvertrag ist nämlich des
wahlrechts mit wahlrecht mit 16 die
abschaffung des paragraphen 219 also man
darf über abtreibung informieren
deutschland soll ein modernes
einwanderungsland werden es sind massive
gesellschafts politische umwälzungen die
die ampel da auf den weg bringt und die
kann ein parteivorsitzender friedrich
merz auch nicht einfach so wieder
zurückdrehen
wir haben auch noch mal eine
zusammenfassung von jetzt der
veranstaltung von auch dem was friedrich
merz der selbst gesagt hatte und hören
jetzt mal zusammen rein ich möchte dass
das aufhört dass aus diesen sitzungen
live berichterstattung in der bild
-zeitung stattfindet ich werde in den
sitzungen darum bitten dass alle ihre
handys draußen lassen und dass wir mal
wieder vertraulich und vertrauensvoll
zusammenarbeiten
kompromisslose ablehnung einer
zusammenarbeit mit der afc ich sage das
gerade weil sie aus thüringen kommen so
etwas was uns da passiert ist wird sich
unter meinem vorsitz nicht wiederholen
wir stellen reden ständig darüber wo wir
überall aussteigen aus der kernenergie
aus der steinkohle aus der braunkohle
wenn möglich jetzt auch demnächst noch
aus der aus der gasverstromung das ist
mir ein bisschen zu viel aufsteigen wir
müssen mal wieder darüber reden wo wir
eigentlich einsteigen wollen
was mich aber korrigieren dass man also
töne vom ersten dezember und jetzt nicht
von zuvor aus seiner dankesrede aber
trotzdem wurden da ja zwei spannende
punkte angesprochen gehen wir vielleicht
erst mal auf den einen ein und zwar
sagte friedrich merz unter ihm werde es
nicht mehr passieren dass da
vertrauliche informationen aus
vertraulichen gesprächen öffentlich
werden und spielt damit darauf an dass
das in der vergangenheit eben häufiger
passiert ist wenn die union an
gesprächen beteiligt war wie möchte er
das vielleicht sicherstellen frau
ramelow hat er dazu was gesagt
ja er hat ja gerade gesagt dass man dann
die handys alle draußen lässt wenn man
sich zu sitzungen trifft ob er das
durchziehen kann oder nicht das werden
wir sehen
aber das ist ja auch das erfolgskonzept
oder war teil des erfolgskonzeptes der
sondierungen und koalitionsverhandlungen
dass hier eben sehr vertrauensvoll
gearbeitet wurde von den drei ampel
parteien und armin laschet hat ja auch
gesagt dass er sehr darunter gelitten
hat das alles immer gleich an die presse
durchgestochen wird und so lässt sich
das der kommentar von friedrich mehr als
ein ordnen im zweiten teil hatte er sich
in sachen klimaschutz geäußert da haben
wir im vorfeld darüber gesprochen dass
das eigentlich auch so ein bisschen
thema war was norbert röttgen der jetzt
nicht verloren hat besetzt hatte wie ist
dann mal was von friedrich merz zu
erwarten in punkto klimaschutz
ja ich meine natürlich ist es ein thema
das kann er nicht ausklammern das ist
vollkommen klar er wird da sicherlich
den wirtschaftlichen aspekt also wie man
klimaschutz wie man die energiewende und
so weiter finanzieren möchte wird
sicherlich eine eine inhaltliche
einflugschneise seien in die ddr in
dieses thema hinein nimmt aber das ist
ein thema das alle bewegt das vor allem
auch die jungen menschen sehr stark
bewegt insofern kann es ja gar nicht
ganz ausklammern ich finde eine frage
noch spannen die ich gerne mitnehmen
würde bei youtube weil ich glaube das
macht auch noch mal gut deutlich was da
jetzt der unterschied ist an diesem
neuen prozess diese mitgliederbefragung
durchgeführt wurde und zwar möchte peter
bei youtube wissen wie kann das so klare
votum für herrn merz erklärt werden
wieso ist herr merz jetzt doch gut genug
nur kurz dass wir das nochmal einordnen
er hatte ja eben schon zweimal zuvor es
nicht geschafft aber ich glaube dass das
können sie uns erklären frau männer ja
es ist eine sehr gute frage aber das
liegt jetzt nicht daran dass friedrich
mehr hat es jetzt einen ganz neuen
schwung in der partei gekriegt hat er
hat ja auch bei den anderen malen immer
nur knapp verloren nein es liegt daran
dass er auch anders gewählt wird bei den
letzten beiden malen als der frau kramp
karrenbauer unterlegen ist
beziehungsweise armin laschet unterlegen
ist waren es ja die delegierten die
abgestimmt haben jetzt sind es die
mitglieder die abgestimmt haben
friedrich merz hat einen hut den sehr
guten draht zur basis ist sehr gut
vernetzt und verdrahtet innerhalb der
partei er hat auf den
regionalkonferenzen die 20 18
stattgefunden haben enormen zuspruch
gekriegt hat sich da auch sehr
reingekniet sich sehr bemüht und so ist
das ergebnis so interpretiert ich würde
mal die these wagen dass die wahl enger
ausgegangen wäre wenn es keine basis
befragung gewesen wäre sondern wenn die
delegierten abgestimmt hätten
wahrscheinlich hätte friedrich merz da
auch die nase vorne gehabt aber das
ergebnis wird lange nicht so klar
gewesen und mit diesem klaren ergebnis
also das hatte der bundesvorstand ja
schon vorher gesagt geht er jetzt also
ganz klar in den parteitag rein das sei
an dieser stelle auch nur noch mal
gesagt also friedrich merz muss auch
noch bestätigt gewählt werden im januar
beim parteitag genau genau und jetzt
schaue ich auch noch mal hier in eure
kommentare nicht dass ich da jetzt hier
noch was vergessen und vielen dank frau
ramelow das remmele dass sie so viel
zeit sich hier gerade nehmen es gibt
nämlich tatsächlich noch fragen und zwar
von maximiliane muster frau wo steht
friedrich merz oder wie steht friedrich
merz zu den themen eu und migration
da hat er sich so stark noch nicht
geäußert ich denke das wird jetzt auch
thema für den anstehenden parteitag
werden aber wie gesagt es ist jetzt die
grosse aufgabe der der partei in der
opposition sich personell und auch
inhaltlich neu aufzustellen und mir
gesagt person und inhalt gehen auch ein
stück weit zusammen vielen dank frau
müller sie haben uns hier wirklich rede
und antwort gestanden eine ganz schön
lange zeit wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit mit tilman kube anzusprechen
aber an dieser stelle erst mal danke
ansehen
und ja er ist mir zugeschaltet themen
kuban der vorsitzende der jungen union
schon guten tag
hallo frau jung und wir haben jetzt
nämlich tatsächlich schon im vorfeld
unserer sendung fragen gehabt online und
haben sie ganz gezielt auch da die frage
schon eingesammelt woran liegt das
eigentlich dass jetzt die jüngeren in
der partei und gerade auch die junge
union und sie auch im speziellen sich im
vorfeld schon klar für friedrich merz
ausgesprochen haben
friedrich merz sorgt für
begeisterungsfähigkeit er ist jemand der
auch neue ideen mitnehmen will der junge
menschen mitnehmen will auf diesem weg
das hat er mit seinem team gezeigt dass
er eben auch mit christina stumpf ein
mitglied der jungen union mit in sein
team genommen hat und deswegen freuen
wir uns auf den gemeinsamen weg hin zu
einer modernen volkspartei es gab da
auch immer wieder kritische stimmen
jetzt bei uns im stream auch hier ein
kommentar von christo miete so ähnlich
heißt die person bei youtube ich finde
nicht dass friedrich merz der richtige
für den umbruch bei der cdu ist wie
würden sie das einschätzen also wie kann
mit friedrich merz 66 jahre alt ein
umbruch gelingen
das alter ist das eine aber ist klar und
offen für neues im kopf und deswegen
freue ich mich schon darauf dass wir
jetzt auch neue themen diskutieren dass
wir ein grundsatzprogramm prozess haben
über die frage wie geht es weiter mit
der union wofür stehen wir eigentlich
noch ich habe nach der wahl gesagt kein
stein darf auf dem anderen bleiben
deswegen ist es jetzt wichtig dass wir
wissen wo sind die tragenden wände eines
hauses um anschließend anzugucken
welcher stein passt doch in dieses haus
und welcher stein welchen stein müssen
wir vielleicht austauschen das wird eine
spannende debatte und die werden wir
auch als junge generation prägen in
dieser partei gemeinsam mit friedrich
merz er ist ein kopf ist jetzt die
führungsfigur aber ich weiß dass er auch
offen ist für neue ideen die wir mit
einbringen werden der generalsekretär
ihrer parteitag hatte jetzt eben gerade
im vorfeld der verkündung des
ergebnisses davon gesprochen dass dies
nur ein teil des erneuerungsprozesses
sei also jetzt der neue vorsitz und hat
angekündigt dass sich die cdu also mit
der frage beschäftigen muss wie stellen
wir uns inhaltlich und strukturell auf
was brauchst also wohl sagen sie was hat
jetzt ein friedrich merz zu liefern um
das auch strukturell zu ändern
zum thema inhaltliche erneuerung habe
ich eben schon etwas gesagt wir müssen
als erstes mal klarmachen was sind
eigentlich unsere grundwerte die wir
alle teilen wir haben seit 2005 zehn
große debatten bei uns in der partei
deswegen müssen wir uns erst einmal
wieder klar werden was uns eigentlich
zusammenhält das ist die inhaltliche
erneuerung anschließend natürlich auch
konkrete konzepte zu erarbeiten mit
denen aus denen wir heraus dann politik
machen und der zweite teil ist bei der
strukturellen erneuerung wir sehen dass
wir eine sehr überall tote
mitgliedschaft haben ich will dass wir
attraktiv offen für neue mitglieder sind
dass wir neue angebote machen also
darüber sprechen wie wir auch vor ort
eigentlich arbeiten zeitgemäß ist es
nicht wenn der vorsitzende erst einmal
eine dreiviertelstunde monolog kate und
danach noch drei mitglieder zu wort
kommen sondern wir müssen hinter aktiver
werden wir müssen die mitglieder mit
einbinden und ich sehe diese offenheit
bei friedrich merz auch dafür zu sorgen
dass wir das wissen das ziel unserer
mitglieder oder potentiellen mitglieder
haben auch abrufbar machen wer bei uns
eintritt der arzt ist oder
finanzbuchhalter oder ähnliches der muss
seine expertise einbringen können er
muss mitmischen können er muss seine
ideen einbringen können dafür müssen wir
einfach für mehr inhaltliche erneuerung
auch sorgen mit den mitgliedern weil nur
wenn man das gefühl hat man kann auch
etwas bewegen in dieser partei dann wird
man auch dabei sein dann werden wir auch
attraktiv sein für neue mitglieder da
freue ich mich ihn dabei zu unterstützen
das junge union zu begleiten jetzt für
den vorsitz hätte ja auch jeder
mitmachen können da jetzt keine frau
dabei kein jüngerer kandidat oder
kandidatin woran liegt das gibt es zu
wenig frauen bei ihm
jetzt sind die letzten 20 jahre von
frauen geführt worden und das waren gute
zeiten für deutschland gute zeiten für
die cdu solange es keine andere partei
in deutschland von einer frau geführt
worden angela merkel aber auch annegret
kramp karrenbauer haben diese partei
geprägt und deswegen müssen wir uns da
glaube ich nicht verstecken jetzt ist
eine zeit für den man vielleicht kommt
danach wieder eine zeit für eine frau
über sie
trotzdem da aber auch noch mal die
nachfrage also jetzt tatsächlich eben
nur drei ältere männer die sich
aufgestellt haben im bundestag auch hat
die cdu also mit ich glaube 23,4 prozent
auch wirklich ein sehr oder die union in
sehr geringen frauenanteil woran liegt
das dass selbst die partei dann nicht
als besonders divers daherkommt
wir haben ja als junge union auch junge
frauen dabei siehe christina stimmt die
jetzt stellvertretende generalsekretärin
wird sie zum beispiel wiebke winter
nadine schön und andere die aus der
jungen generation kommen die franziska
hoppermann war jetzt mit dabei im team
von norbert röttgen da sind viele junge
frauen die drängen nach vorne in unserer
generation mache ich mir da keine sorgen
da sehe ich viele attraktive
interessante junge frauen die neue ideen
ein ringen werden die nicht nur frauen
sind sondern die vor allem auch klug
sind und neue ideen mitbringen deswegen
freue ich mich da auch schon auf die
nächsten debatten ein kommentar von
facebook würde ich gerne noch aufgreifen
das schreibt carsten wilke dadurch kann
die cdu vielleicht wähler von der afg
zurückgewinnen doch werden sie potenzial
in der mitte verlieren die spd wird es
freuen ist das so dass friedrich merz
jetzt ein ball eher als konservativ gilt
da jetzt also auch vielleicht wähler von
der afg zurückgewinnt glauben sie dass
friedrich merz hat als einziger ein
komplementäres team aufgestellt ein team
von mario czaja der aus dem osten kommt
aus einer großstadt der sozialpolitiker
ist bis hin zu christina stumpf die aus
dem ländlichen raum kommt die
kommunalpolitikerin ist also stadt und
land ost und west jung und alt und das
ist etwas was ihn auszeichnet er will
alle mitnehmen und genau das ist es was
eine partei der mitte auch am ende
auszeichnung ist ich habe noch mehr
fragen ganz konkret einsehbar ins im
stream peter bei youtube möchte gerne
wissen welche personalentscheidungen
stehen unter märz an welche leute werden
aus ihrer sicht herr kuban jetzt er
nennt es ausgetauscht
wir werden jetzt erst einmal darüber
diskutieren dass wir auch wieder einen
attraktiven bundesvorstand wählen das
wird in den nächsten wochen sicherlich
einige diskussionen hervorrufen dann
schauen wir mal wer dort mit ihm im team
antritt ich wünsche mir sehr dass wir
starke persönlichkeiten haben die auch
für themen stehen die auch neue
personengruppen adressieren können denn
am ende ist politik keine one man show
sondern ist ein großes team spielt und
dafür müssen wir auch als cdu stehen und
wir hatten im vorfeld wir sind ja schon
eine weile hier live hatten wir auch
immer wieder das thema klimaschutz ja
auch angesprochen die ist denn da von
friedrich merz ganz klar die haltung wie
wird sich denn die cdu da jetzt
ausrichten
friedrich merz sagt ja beispielsweise
auch im vorfeld der wahl ein gemeinsames
papier mit der klima union erarbeitet
also von daher ist ja sehr
fortschrittlich auch in diesem bereich
unterwegs und ich glaube dass da ein
falsches bild auch von ihnen gezeichnet
wird ich erlebe ihn als jemand der sehr
offen ist auch das thema energiewende
als eines der wesentlichen themen des
klimaschutzes ist auch zu gestalten auch
neue konzepte als cdu dort zu
präsentieren und deswegen freue ich mich
dort auf die weitere debatte die wir
führen werden und da sehe ich ihn als
sehr offen an wir haben zum beispiel
auch mit andreas jung einen echten
klimaexperten der als stellvertretender
parteivorsitzender kandidiert die cdu
wird sich darauf einen modernen kurs
machen weil wir wollen eine moderne
volkspartei sei ein paar unserer user
sind da noch kritisch ich möchte nur
einen kommentar vorlesen gerner streich
schreibt bei youtube bei allem respekt
aber märz das ist vergangenheit er ist
für die wirtschaft gut aber nicht für
die arbeitnehmer und das klima da
vielleicht auch noch mal bei ihnen
nachgefragt sie haben am anfang unseres
interviews gesagt er sei
begeisterungsfähig sind es aber auch die
wirtschaftsthemen die sie mitgenommen
haben was hat sie ganz konkret als junge
union denn an ihm so so begeistert
also was nicht begeistert seine
offenheit beispielsweise für das thema
digitalisierung dass wir eben digitaler
werden dass wir ein digitaler staat
werden dass wir auch unsere parteiarbeit
digitalisieren und das ist etwas wo er
auch jemand der vielleicht älter ist
trotzdem offen ist für neues und das ist
etwas was mich sehr anspricht was ich
sehr gut findet beispielsweise im
bereich der digitalen bildung wieder
dass wir neue konzepte entwickeln
erfordert uns auf auch im bereich der
rentenpolitik klare konzepte zu haben
dass wir wieder deutlicher werden nicht
einfach den demografischen wandel auf
uns zu laufen lassen sondern dort klare
konzepte zu entwickeln und das ist etwas
was ich gut finde und wo ich ihnen als
sehr fortschrittlich an sehr andere
parteien verschweigen einfach das
problem herr kuban zum schluss noch an
sie die frage hier von youtube von
markus zink wie sehr entscheidend
ergebnisse kommen da landtagswahlen die
zukunft von friedrich merz
da die landtagswahlen werden natürlich
wichtig sein im nächsten jahr wir haben
drei entscheidenden landtagswahlen im
saarland in schleswig holstein aber auch
in nordrhein-westfalen und wir haben
drei hervorragende ministerpräsidenten
mit tobias hans mit daniel günther und
mit hendrik wüst die zur wahl stehen und
wir werden sie als junge union voll
unterstützen und ich glaube auch
friedrich merz wird sie mit vollem
herzen unterstützen weil wir davon
überzeugt sind dass sie in guten job
machen und dass sie weitermachen sollten
und dass sie ihm gute ideen für die drei
bundesländer haben deswegen volle
unterstützung sagte man koban von der
jungen union vielen lieben dank
vielen dank ihnen
und mir kommen jetzt auch zum ende das
war jetzt auch eine ganze strecke die
wir hier gemeinsam gemacht haben
vielleicht noch mal zum schluss erinnern
wir uns noch mal alle was dabei
rausgekommen wir haben ja eine weile
gewartet und jetzt ist ein ergebnis da
eine absolute mehrheit für friedrich
merz mit
62,1 prozent an zweiter stelle landete
norbert röttgen
25,8 prozent
und an dritter stelle dann helge braun
mit 12,1 prozent das war also sehr klar
eine absolute mehrheit für friedrich
merz und damit gilt er also klar als
nominiert und wird es auch beim
parteitag also vorgeschlagen dann im
januar und dann wird quasi gewählt
nochmal erst dann gilt als fest
bestätigt und wir danken jetzt erstmal
für die aufmerksamkeit für die vielen
fragen und kommentare und sind auch
nächste woche wieder für euch live bis
dahin tschüss